and we're just gonna break into that
program to bring you some breaking news
Sky News understands that the Dutchess
of Sussex has gone into labor there has
been fevered speculation over the last
few days as to when Harry and Megan's
baby might arrive had it arrived already
were she already in labor
lots of gossip lots of rumor but what we
know now for a fact communicated to us
from royal circles is that Meghan has
now gone into labor
officially let's talk to our royal
correspondent Rhiannon Mills who can
join us on the phone Rhiannon so this is
the news er that a lot of royal watchers
have been waiting for quite a long time
for for nine months in fact indeed they
have and you'll remember it was back at
the start of their first major overseas
tour in Australia and New Zealand that
it was confirmed to us to all of the
royal journalists who traveled with
Harry and Megan that they were due to be
expecting their first child in the
spring
at no point however has it been
confirmed by the palace exactly when the
Duchess Sussex was June it was however
Megan during a walkabout in Birkenhead
when she was meeting crowds who told few
women there but she was due to expect
her first child around April and May so
that's why many of us lots of
international journalists have all
started gathering here in Windsor
waiting for the news and finally it was
confirmed me about ten minutes ago that
it was in the early hours of this
morning that the Duchess of Sussex went
into labor and also confirmed to me that
the Duke of Sussex was by her side now
it was always anticipated that Palace
were going to tell us when she went into
labor
the next announcement that of course we
are waiting for is when we finally will
hear the news that the baby has been
born
what is also making it slightly
different around the arrival of Harry
and Megan's first child is that I think
in the past with royal babies recently
we've been used to they're waiting
outside of the Lindo wing waiting for
William and Kate come out and show us
that their baby for the first time and
we're not going to see that this time
there is no hospital for
outside of because Harry and Megan had
decided that they want to keep their new
arrival as private as possible and
Rhiannon also some speculation that she
may be going for a home birth which some
people may question but of course the
Queen herself had four home births
didn't she
it's been so interesting there has been
so much discussion about whether or not
this couple breaking with with royal
tradition is it the right thing that
they want to keep this baby so private
of course their child is going to be
seventh in line throne there's no major
constitutional change that we can expect
by the arrival of this child also we
haven't had it confirmed that she's
definitely having a home birth so it
could well be that we still have it
confirmed once the baby's born but
actually they were admitted hospital at
some point this morning but we are and
we'll still have to wait to hear those
those details and I think it was all
it's always with this couple been a case
of them wanting to make their own
choices we've so much hungry about how
they are a very modern young royal
couple how they wanted to do things
their own way how they've already been
shaking things up a little bit and
showing that they have their own unique
style when it comes to official
engagements or the kind of charities
that they want to focus on and so I
think again with the fact that they want
to try and maintain as much the privacy
around the arrival of their child once
again they are there sitting down there
their markers really and showing how as
a family of three they want things to go
forward so that's been a bit more
information that you didn't quite give
us at the top Ariana and so you're
saying that they're all couple have gone
into hospital so we at the moment as far
as we know they are not at Frogmore
cottage and it is potentially not a home
Bursar's now at the moment I probably
wasn't entirely clear what I was saying
is we don't entirely know where she's
having this baby what I do know is that
when it's finally confirmed that the
baby has been born we can expect the
details of where she gave birth the
weight of the baby the time that the
baby was born but at the moment I think
there's been so many people saying oh
she's definitely having a home birth and
that isn't necessarily the case I think
we could potentially still find
that she was taken to maybe friendly
Park which is very nearby what the
countess Wessex had her two children she
could also have she could also
potentially have gone to Chelsea and
Westminster which is where we know that
one of her friends Amal Clooney had her
twins at moment there is still a lot of
speculation about exactly where the
Duchess of Sussex is at the moment where
she is with her husband but it was
confirmed to me that the baby is on its
way and that the Duchess of Sussex went
into labour first thing this morning and
also that Prince Harry who was by her
side and you touched on on succession
and and the possibilities of other
titleist this will be the seventh in
line to the throne won't it so it so
that there isn't been a bumping down of
those that are in the Royal line of
succession further down the list that's
right and I think in a way that sport
has taken the pressure off Harry and
Megan as a couple and meant that they
can in a way make their own decisions
about when they want to announce to the
world that their child has been born and
also this decision that they've made
that they they don't want to have a big
public press call once their child has
been born as we saw around the Duke and
Duchess of Cambridge it does give them
more flexibility but you cannot forget
that they are currently the rockstar
royal couple of the moment they are the
ones that everyone is focusing on and
that's something that has amazed me
really being here for the last week the
numbers of TV crews the number of
reporters from right across the world
who are gathering for this moment I'm
told that when it comes to some of the
American TV networks they are going to
have breaking coverage they'll be
breaking into their news coverage as we
speak to announce that she's gone into
labour they will then have rolling
coverage and I think that's also
something that is different and special
about this baby for the first time you
are going to have a member of the royal
family who is entitled to both dual
American and British heritage despite
the fact that they will be seventh in
line to the throne and not
thoroughly entitled to those titles of
being a prince or princess but yeah at
the moment we are waiting to find out
whether we're gonna have a little boy or
a little girl
entering royal family and so for the
next few hours
it's basically watch this space
speculation but when we do here there is
a chance that they may release an image
themselves might and day they have their
their Instagram feed so that that could
be a possible first place that we could
catch an image of this new baby yeah
that's right and I think that's them
certainly over the last week as I've
been waiting the Dutchess of Sussex to
go into into labor you do start thinking
oh gosh I wonder how how they're going
to announce it on their own social media
accounts because we've been caught seen
their their new Instagram account was
was set up a few weeks ago hugely
popular broke records when it came to
getting a record number of followers and
at the moment we anticipate that there
will be a very small photo call probably
a few days after the baby's been born so
we will get those official photographs
but yeah they are a young modern couple
and whether or not we will see maybe a
little glimpse of the baby on Instagram
we'll just have to wait and see